-I'm Karen.
-I'm Barry.
And we own Circus of Books.
I thought it was just a bookstore...
with a circus theme.
Circus of Books was the center
of the gay universe.
Just like porn, P-O-R-N.
If anyone asked us what our parents did...
These are called cock rings.
...the official answer was...
We own a bookstore.
Porn has always had a place
in the gay community.
To see men naked and unafraid.
They're not offended,
they're not scandalized.
It's their job.
This guy here, Handjobs Magazine,
now he does organic chicken farming.
So when I order from him,
we catch up on his chickens.
This is the face
of Santa Monica Boulevard.
In the '80s, if you could sell adult
material, you could make a lot of money.
We were probably the biggest distributor
of hardcore gay film in the United States.
But I never felt free
to let anybody know what we did.
Mom was caught between
this stuffy, conservative synagogue
and the business.
It was like a knife over our heads
all the time.
We just were completely kept in the dark.
Are you okay?
There's more than 800 cases nationwide,
and yet still,
surprisingly few people are familiar with
the Acquired Immune Deficiency Syndrome.
We lost so many of our employees.
We would call the parents
to say, "Hey, your son is sick."
The parents would just say,
"I never wanna see the guy again."
"But he's your son."
They didn't set out to support
the gay community,
but they were not gonna let other forces
tell them what to do.
Circus of Books was my first glimpse
into the fact that
I wasn't alone as a gay person.
To be a homo was unspeakable.
This bookstore,
it kept me out of harm's way.
No one has ever given us anything
we haven't had to fight for.
I think what we did
was small human kindnesses
in a very small way.
-You guys made all of those?
-Yeah. Those sent you to college.